[Music]
bro everyone's gonna be mad at us
because we didn't go in on that Mark
Wahlberg video what video where he like
mocks his or he mocks Tina
who
oh man
I I
had a lot of people dming me yep that's
the one that's the one play this one
no no no you gotta
hold on
Mark Wahlberg am I
he blocked me no just kidding
nah can you pull up the one go to yeah
that's the one play this one let it rip
this is the one this is the one we all
got tagged are you getting the shoes
Tina
get the shoes look
this is the dream the plan
and the hustle that's awesome look at
that see that what's so funny listen why
do I wear Municipal every day he asked
me the earlier because when you're
building a brand you have to represent
the brand every day of the dream the
plan the hustle the draws everything get
the shoes Tina
get the shoes
oh get the shoes god who's Tina why are
you laughing it's his wife
no right
yeah man
isn't that his wife look up his wife's
name
Raya oh zarya
Ria Durham
that's how he'd say it yeah
Tina why the [__] are you laughing Tina
you're [__] fired all right it's not
joking it's Municipal all right
when you're building a brand you got to
wear it every [__] day Gotta Stay
prayed up
that's what he says that's what Mark
says
I think this is
yeah yep
yep
happy National Prayer day stay prayed up
God bless you
God bless
God bless you Dave what does stay prayed
up mean
I stay prayed up man
I mean come on now
you gotta stay prayed uh
should I be praying all the time
what is all right wait okay so
go to go to all right like when someone
says you want to stay like fit it up it
means like you gotta always be wearing
nice clothes or like cool you gotta stay
prayed up man you gotta stay always be
praying or like always be yeah kind of
praying or just being always always be
connected with God I think is what he's
saying
right
got it dude go back go to go to his Tick
Tock before we get out of here father
son Holy Spirit brother son Holy Spirit
show the one play the one and prayed up
can you go to his uh Instagram
[Music]
there's one he has with
Mario Lopez
yeah that's a great one yeah right but
this looks like us dude yeah it really
does
all right this is us and the funniest
part of it you can tell how small they
are
camera camera
[Laughter]
they look like two wemies dude
and Mario Lopez's head and His Hands
weirdly look massive he looks like a
Roblox character it's everything about
this dude
it's too [__] us
if I play with volume I gotta hear oh
man happy Mother's Day absolutely keep
each other accountable and make you all
proud stay prayed up God bless Mama stay
prayed up God bless you
thank you
all right so are they thirst traffic I
know
Play It Again
God Bless The Mamas oh happy Sunday yes
and Happy Mother's day God bless all the
mamas out there I got two Mama's Boys
right here that's right all the moms
babe all the moms love you God bless you
we know we'd be nothing without you
thank you thank you thank you every day
should be Mother's Day absolutely
keeping each other accountable and I
make you all proud stay prayed up God
bless Mama
Mario Lopez have a sore throat why does
he sound like that God damn that was
tough to watch
it really is but it's tough to watch
why do they want to [__] the moms God
damn God damn I mean God damn
that was darn yeah yeah which every day
if I had it my way if I had it my way
I'd stay prayed up I every day would be
National Prayer day and no every day
would be Mother's Day or some
combination of the two maybe it would
alternate between them National Prayer
day and then Mother's Day
me
happy Mother's Day oh the doggone moms
stay prayed up
holy Donna all these moms and I know the
comments on that are horrendous like yes
happy Mother's Day to this mama right
here men who put God first is damn sexy
like do you think Mark was like Mario
you got to get over here and yep
I never use the phrase break the
internet
Mario let me tell you it's gonna go
crazy right now I'll put on this
Municipal t-shirt
and we're gonna [__] we're gonna
shout out all the moms right now in
front of my huge cross
that we're gonna break the internet
brother
I just want to find
the one
the one like inappropriate mom comment
we're like well God damn
I get on my knees for these you know
just
it's not happening
weirdly tame yeah
well hey I guess on Mother's Day it
would be
it would be here we go here we go they
are still two of the hottest guys in
Hollywood and they're both Christians
and they're Catholic
he's Catholic
which makes them even more appealing
holy [__] dude oh you saw that one my
due date is soon
no which
look at that
oh because she's she's pregnant
yeah or maybe he's just genuinely that
looks like a I don't know who that is
how does Mario look like a bobble head
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
damn it dude
drip trips so so fit
municipala it's a pal
love it
okay
well
well folks
I think that's it for these episodes
yeah gang it's uh
it's [__] 12 30 a.m over here in
sunny Glasgow get to bed
yeah
I need to get some z's yeah thanks for
joining us and we'll see you next wheeze
good bees
it could be